OK, one of the biggest justifications that
the open everything crowd has given for why
everything should always have been open throughout
the pandemic. This includes Trump, Republicans,
Fox News hosts, everybody would. The justification
was quarantines, guidelines, so-called lockdowns.
Even though the U.S. didn't have lockdowns,
that is causing suicides to explode.
Suicides are way up, except we now know that it
was completely untrue. We now have the suicide
numbers from twenty twenty. We can know whether
that actually happened and the thought went, sure,
people might die from covid if things are
open, but people will die by suicide if things
are closed. Trump endlessly said it. Suicides
are up, suicides suicide. Here's one example.
A prolonged lockdown, combined with a forced
economic depression would inflict an immense
and wide ranging toll on public health. This
includes a sharp rise in drug abuse, alcohol
abuse, suicide, heart disease and many other
dimensions of physical and mental well-being.
Moreover, many patients have put needed
medical care on hold, creating entirely
new hazards for public health. A country
has suffered. The world has suffered severe.
Here's another example of Trump making the same
claim on the H-1B model, which is now filling the
34000 that by all this doubling of free permits.
And are you concerned that that's happening with
some of these states are relaxing guidelines?
No, I'm not, because that that assumes no
mitigation, that we're going to have mitigation
now. We're letting people out. But the fact that
we're letting people go and go to their jobs, they
have to do it, you know, if they help people any
longer with the shutdowns and. To lose people
that way, too, and you already have, I'm sure,
but between drug abuse and I mean they
say suicide, a lot of different things.
Suicides weigh up. I could play a dozen,
two dozen, three dozen fifty one hundred of
these clips of Trump and other Republicans
talking about suicide, suicide, suicides,
suicides were down in the United States in 2020.
We now have the numbers. They claimed it without
evidence. Lots of people fell for it. Many
people repeated it. And it simply was not
true. Suicides in the United States decreased
in 2020, according to early data from the CDC.
Suicides in 2020 believed to be the lowest in
five years, roughly on par with the lowest in
six years, according to the new CDC data.
Suicides declining five point six percent
in 2020 from twenty nineteen. Now, just because
they were wrong, as they almost always are,
doesn't mean there aren't issues of concern here.
This doesn't mean there won't be serious long term
psychological effects from the pandemic. There
will be PTSD, agoraphobia, the continued feeling
that the world is dangerous. And, you know,
we have to stay home. We have to stay hidden.
It's a long list and there will be serious
consequences for years. And yes, part of it
will be from the isolation of the pandemic. Part
of it will be from people getting covid and dying
or having a friend or family member who got covid
and died. But the notion that the covid prevention
efforts did more harm than good because suicides
are way up is simply not true. The economy is
recovering very nicely. The U.S. government
should have done more during the bottom,
no doubt about it. But we are seeing that the
quote lockdown's, which weren't lockdown's,
did not do irreparable harm to the U.S. economy.
It did it change the economy, the economy we
have at the end of this year, it's going to be
different than the one that we had in January of
twenty twenty, no doubt about it. The other issue,
just because death by suicide was down in 2020
doesn't mean any great victory. It was down five
percent. Nearly 45000 people still died by suicide
in the United States in 2020. That's horrible.
That has to be dealt with. That is still a crisis.
But the point is suicide didn't explode because
of the guidelines that were recommended by public
health experts. One other note, suicide
could be down, but depression could be up.
And we still need to deal with that. That
also has to be looked at. So this is not about
everything they said should have been ignored.
It's about one of their main empirical claims.
Suicides are way up was factually wrong.
One other note. The takeaway for me
is not the isolation and the guidelines and the
distancing aren't so bad. That's not really an
interesting takeaway. It's not an actionable
takeaway for me. It's more about we should have
a more flexible system as a matter of status quo
so that people who do better with work from home
can do it. We have the technology for it.
There's no reason not to, and increasingly,
if you look at what's happening, happening with
office space demand, it seems as though that is
a change that will become at least potentially
semi-permanent in the economy. But they were
wrong. Again, no explosion in suicides, suicides
down five percent. Now, if you or someone you know
is not doing well, maybe considering suicide,
there are free resources available. OK,
the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline,
you can call it 24 hours a day, 800 273.
Eighty two. Fifty five. OK, free 24 hours a day,
one 800 273. Eighty two. Fifty five available to
you. Make it available to anyone. You know
the crisis text line. If you don't want to
get on the phone with someone, if you prefer
to text, that's fine. You can text the word
home to seven four one seven four one. That's
the 24/7 free crisis text line. There are
resources available. Make sure you know them. Make
sure other people, you know, are aware of them.